[Music]
okay so up top i'm gonna preface the
video by saying that i got sent these
leaks from an email account that said
they'd had access to the spider-man no
way home trailer whilst i don't know for
definite if this stuff will be in the
teaser which is rumored to be released
next week at some point i did follow up
on the email find the person on linkedin
and judging by their job history i think
it seems very likely that they're
connected to one of the companies that
would be putting it out in the past when
i've done leaks like this i've always
said that if he connected to one of the
companies and would rather this info
wasn't out yet then just message me on
twitter at heavy spoilers and i'll
happily private the video now with all
that being said there is quite a lot of
big things to take from the teaser if my
source isn't detailing the truth the big
bombshells in the first look which we've
discussed on previous videos include
several hints towards the sinister six
and a big appearance by dr octopus at
the end of it in which he says hello
peter now octopus is played by none
other than alfred molina and he's been
the aged for the trailer in which we see
a tentacle come into frame and then
hoist him up which is where we close it
on his face and he utters the line in my
prior video i said that this was the
last shot but the person actually
cleared it up and said that it's not the
final one though it is near the end they
said that what we close out on is
actually peter and his iron spider
updated suit and it's just sort of him
suiting up basically and that's a kind
of pointless detail but my source said
that they just wanted to clarify that
there are however other teasers to the
sinister six in the trailer and
apparently we get yellow electricity
above a group of policemen and also a
point in which it fires at peter this is
clearly electro another person said it's
difficult to make them out they have
changed his electricity from blue to
yellow to keep it in line with the
comics him firing at peter is actually
blocked by a wall of sand which shoots
up to stop it and this is clearly the
sandman next is the lizard who shoots
out in a jump scare moment when peter is
exploring the sanctum sanctorum and the
last member of the six that were meant
to get at ease towards is the green
goblin when a pumpkin bomb rolls towards
the screen now the more astute ones of
you will have realized that there's only
five members there and i asked the
person why there wasn't six in the
trailer and they said that they were
definitely the only characters that were
shown in the first look that they saw
don't know why that is but yeah again
that's just what they said now the
trailer itself apparently opens months
and months after peter has already
cleared his name he and mj are set
sitting on a roof and the latter reads a
newspaper while she talks about the
article in it she reads a paragraph out
loud that says people believe that the
male spider's gaze has hypnotized
several females and this sort of
foreshadows what's to come i asked the
luca if we get any more stuff explaining
how peter's name was cleared and they
said there were some brief moments in
the trailer such as him being in a
police station saying it wasn't him we
also apparently see ned being questioned
along with aunt may and there's meant to
be a brief shot in which we see peter
handcuffed to a desk now if all this is
right and you're here after the trailer
has released then you've got a thumbs up
the video and if i'm wrong then that's
what the dislike is for too either way
though i'd love it if you subscribe so
you can keep up to date with the end
result as it's gonna be interesting to
see whether this turns out to be true or
whether it turns out that i'm a massive
clown if this is your first time here
then welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man now let's get
into the rest of the trailer info
okay so in addition to the above we're
meant to get shots of peter walking into
what could be a courtroom and there are
crowds behind barriers booing him as he
struts in he's joined by mj ned and also
flash thompson who now has his hair dyed
blonde when i said strut there i just
meant walking i didn't mean he was
walking along the street pointing at
people now from the rooftop scenes we
very much get the feeling that peter
just wants to return to a normal life
and then in the trailer we watch as he
visits doctor strange in order to ask
him a big favor peter apparently wants
to know if there's a way to reverse time
and stop mysterio from doing what he
does but instead strange ends up casting
a spell that makes the world forget that
he's spider-man the exchange between
them is meant to be pretty funny and
peter goes back and forth over whether
to call him sir or not the person who
sent me the info said it's very similar
to what happens in infinity war when
peter says they're using their made up
names and we also get an appearance by
another big character one can be seen
walking around in the background and
he's packing to go off somewhere on
vacation he says that it's dangerous to
cast that spell and then strange says he
won't and then gives peter a wink now
one could be going off to star in
chongqi and though we don't know that
for definite it just kind of lines up
with what we know is in that film now
they travel into the basement and
strange uses one of peter's hairs
similar to when he grabbed one from thor
in ragnarok
he starts the spell but peter interrupts
this and asks if those that already knew
before the mysterio reveal can still
remember strange says don't interrupt
the spell but peter keeps pushing and
this messes it up which is when reality
seemingly breaks open this is when we
get the rest of the shots in the trailer
with the villain teasers and also new
york being attacked my source also said
there's a big chase scene in the mirror
dimension across new york and we can see
peter falling through the city as it
bends and twists around him strange is
chasing him at this point and he also
follows him on a train in which he picks
up several of the carriages and tosses
them towards him judging by other plot
leaks that are out on the net this is
because peter steals a magical cube from
the sanctum sanctorum that is being used
to house the villains in place in the
basement the user said there's also a
point in which strange pushes peter's
astral form out of his body and they
even sent some fanart and said that this
is pretty much what happens the user
said that the angle in the trailer was
actually a flip of this but that it
looked very very similar now that's
pretty much all of the major information
that they told me they said that the
trailer was coming shortly and that this
video would be proven to be right so
fingers crossed i haven't looked like a
massive clown laying it all out like
this i probably only do about four plot
league videos a year right now because
it's very easy to be wrong and i don't
want to be one of those channels that
posts a no way home video a week that
completely contradicts the last one
however my scrutiny to leaks means that
i've managed to keep somewhat of a good
track record and i do do my research
when looking up sources as it probably
gets sent about five to ten leaks a week
now i know a lot of you have asked why i
haven't done any shangchi leaks and in
the case of that it's because i actually
know what happens in the film due to
some of my friends attending screenings
for it and telling me what happens with
leaks you only tend to really get leeway
legally if you don't know things for
sure and i feel a bit weird just leaking
the end of a movie knowing that it could
get my friends in trouble now leaking a
trailer is a bit different to a movie
but as i said if you're from sonia
marvel and want this video offline until
after it releases then just message me
on twitter at heavyspoilers and i'll
private it until you eventually decide
to give us that good stuff in the
meantime though i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the leak so make sure you
comment below and let me know if you
believe it if you don't if you hear from
the future and you know it's true if you
hear from the future and you know what's
wrong let me know in the comments below
the comment section is yours do as you
please now we are running a competition
right now and giving away three mcu box
sets on the 30th of august all you have
to do to be in with the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the video if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of what if episode 2 which
will be linked on screen right now we've
gone over the full thing from top to
bottom and talked about all the cool
little things in it so definitely go
check it out right after this if not
then thank you for sitting until the end
of the video i've been paul i'll see you
next time take care peace
so
[Music]
you